[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir le gouvernement encore
une fois mise à l'épreuve dans
l'hémicycle après les débats de censure
hier le projet de loi de programmation
budgétaire 2023 2027 a été rejeté enfin
dame après-midi par l'Assemblée
nationale un nouveau revers qui en dit
long sur les difficultés de l'exécutif
on y reviendra mais au-delà on va
s'interroger sur nos déficits publics
les ramener à 3% en 5 ans est-ce que
c'est souhaitable mais surtout est-ce
que c'est possible dans ce contexte de
multicrises grand débat dans un instant
avec nos invités sur ce plateau c'est le
livre donc tout le monde parle
l'histoire mondiale des riches par
l'historien Fabrice d'Almeida chez plan
radiographie des 10 000 personnes les
plus riches de la planète vous le verrez
ils ont changé les riches en un siècle
un livre qui tombe à point nommer en
plein débat sur la rémunération des
grands patrons et la taxation des super
profits à l'Assemblée on a plein de
questions à à Fabrice dalmena dans la
deuxième partie enfin ce seront les
partis pris de nos affranchis ce soir
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée signée
Stéphanie Despierres les députés et la
corrida la sondeuse Céline braque de
doxa la baisse du pouvoir d'achat fait
plonger l'exécutif dans l'opinion et
puis la féministe Léa chamboncelle
pourquoi les hommes sont toujours mieux
payés que les femmes dans notre pays
voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
bonsoir à chaque séance au Palais
Bourbon sont lot de problèmes les
macronistes viennent à nouveau d'essuyer
les vents contraires des oppositions on
va tout vous expliquer dans le détail
c'est assez baroque vous allez le voir
la loi de programmation budgétaire
2023-2027 a été rejeté il y a à peine
quelques heures quelles conséquences sur
le sérieux budgétaire promis par la
France à Bruxelles bonsoir Charles si
jeune stool j'espère que je n'écorche
pas votre nom député renaissance du
Bas-Rhin membre de la commission des
finances dans laquelle vous siégé
également Philippe un bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau député
socialiste de l'Eure et membre de la
nupaisse bonsoir marvinho journaliste au
Point vous suivez des politiques
économiques à Bercy mais l'ensemble du
gouvernement et puis l'économiste
François girolles de l'omce va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
juste après le billet de Blacko parce
qu'il faut y voir un peu plus clair ce
soir ça s'est passé il y a quelques
heures dans l'hémicycle si bien compris
on commence avec la mi blackovski comme
chaque soir
[Musique]
alors si j'ai bien compris ce soir
Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
messieurs si j'ai bien compris Myriam la
LPF c'est à dire la loi de programmation
des finances publiques un peu servi de
punching ball à l'opposition
c'est-à-dire chaque groupe de position
s'est mis à cogner sur cette loi
histoire de montrer ses muscles et
surtout de rappeler au gouvernement
qu'ils n'ont plus la majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée désormais donc le sort de
cette pauvre LPFP n'a pas été toujours
facile rejeté en commission rochetez
aujourd'hui définitivement et lorsque le
texte a été examiné le 10 octobre il y a
cet article sur 26 qui ont été rejetés
la tension est montée ce genre dans
l'hémicycle les débats sont finis à 2h30
et le ministre du Budget bon il était en
colère il était fâché en écoute
ce qui s'est passé ce soir sur ce texte
et grave
c'est grave pour notre pays le message
qui a été envoyé c'est qu'une coalition
de l'irresponsabilité à envoyer l'image
d'un pays
qui est incapable de se fixer comme
objectif de maîtriser sa dépense
publique
alors évidemment on a aussi des bons
orateurs du côté de l'opposition est-ce
que vous croyez qu'on peut traiter André
Chassaigne 20 ans de Parlement
d'irresponsable mais je crois que non
madame
vous n'avez pas monsieur le ministre
à traiter les députés d'irresponsables
comme vous le faites
vous vous comportez
vous comportez non seulement
comment
respecte pas la représentation nationale
l'AFP ça fait monter la température et
ça ça s'active
à cette loi de programmation budgétaire
effectivement l'opposition tout le monde
est contre pour taper sur ce texte en
l'occurrence mais pas pour les mêmes
raisons donc du côté de la nupesse
excusez-moi ce qu'on reproche au
gouvernement en fait c'est d'être obsédé
par la réduction du déficit budgétaire
donc de mener une politique d'austérité
pour réduire ce déficit avec ses
objectifs d'avoir un déficit inférieur à
3% du PIB en 2027 donc voilà ce que on
reproche du côté du PS c'est votre
collègue PS qui va le dire ne dites pas
qu'il l'a pas dit on l'écoute
rassurer les marchés rassurer la
Commission européenne rassurer la Cour
des comptes rassurer rassurer rassurer
justement à quel moment avons-nous prévu
de rassurer les Français et les
Françaises et donc du côté du République
on s'oppose aussi au texte mais pour une
raison complètement opposée c'est un
sentiment que la LPFP prévoit pas assez
d'économie justement pour lutter contre
augmentation de la dette augmentation du
déficit et donc voilà ce que reproche au
texte Véronique plus vas-y des
républicains
monsieur le ministre nous savons tous
que le redressement des comptes publics
exige du courage et imposent beaucoup
d'efforts mais si le dès le début de la
législature vous ne donnez aucune
ambition ou si vous témoignez de si peu
de volonté alors comment croire que nous
pourrons redresser la barre d'ici 5 ans
bon voilà c'est très clair les
oppositions s'opposent pour des raisons
inverse quelles conséquences risque
d'avoir ce rejet ce texte alors là
j'espère que quelqu'un a une idée sur le
sujet parce que c'est pas forcément très
clair quand on écoute le gouvernement ou
la majorité parce que d'un côté on
écoute genre on est Cazeneuve et on a
l'impression que le rejet de cette
prophétie ce projet de loi quand même
des grosses conséquences notamment
vis-à-vis de l'union de l'Union
européenne on l'écoute
au-delà du fait que c'est la mitraille
en péril nous engagements budgétaires
prenons conscience que cette que cette
non adoption pourrait entraîner un
retard voire une amputation des fonds
européens qui nous sont versés dans le
cadre du plan de relance
qui pourraient nous passer sous le nez
non ça ne vous inquiète pas mais nous
téléspectateurs se disent mon Dieu
qu'est-ce qui se passe le problème c'est
que quand on demande à Franck Riester
qui lui est ministre des Relations avec
le Parlement qu'on lui dit mais ce que
ça ne serait pas grave si cette projet
loi était rejeté il a pas l'air plus
inquiet que ça lui prend crister on
l'écoute si elle devait ne pas être
votée a priori il n'y a pas d'impact
très important en matière de budget par
exemple et donc nous n'utiliserions pas
le 49-3 si cette loi est ne pouvait pas
passer si nous ne trouvions pas une
majorité pour la voter ça serait pas
très grave donc il y en a un qui dit que
c'est grave qui ne fait pas grave c'est
pas facile de trancher sont des sujets
importants fondamentaux
sont de plus en plus conscients comme le
montre un sondage car Radio Classique
récemment je vous montre les chiffres
qui en ressortent vous voyez que
l'inquiétude est présente en gros 80%
d'entre nous se disent inquiet à la fois
par le niveau des déficits et par niveau
de la dette à tel point qu'il y a même
une majorité aujourd'hui de Français qui
imaginent que la France serait pourrait
faire faillite donc il y a quand même
une vraie inquiétude de ce point-là ça
veut dire qu'ils sont favorables à
l'austérité les Français mais oui mais
bien sûr il la réclame l'austérité des
Français regardez les sondages le disent
vous pouvez pas dire le contraire 56%
des Français estiment que la priorité
c'est plutôt la réduction des déficits
plutôt que nous soutien à la croissance
alors il y a juste un petit problème mon
point de vue je suis pas un spécialiste
du budget mais quand on demande aux
Français alors quels sont vos mesures
budgétaires favorites regardez en fait
sur ces mesures il y en a deux qui
rapportent de l'argent c'est la taxe sur
les super profits et l'augmentation du
prix du tabac et tout le reste c'est des
dépenses supplémentaires donc les
Françaises qui veulent c'est très simple
en fait c'est donc réduire le déficit en
augmentant les dépenses mais est-ce que
c'est possible je vous laisse débattre
moi je dépasse mes compétences merci
beaucoup merci Stéphane alors Charles
ciddenstool déjà sur ce qui s'est passé
ce soir dans la séquence parce que c'est
après 3 49,3 3 débats de censure se
rejet d'un texte dont on comprend très
bien que même s'il n'a pas d'impact tout
de suite c'est de la programmation
budgétaire il s'agit quand même de la
signature de la France vis-à-vis de
Bruxelles ça commence à faire beaucoup
de difficultés pour vous là bon alors
sur le vote d'aujourd'hui le calendrier
là pour le coup c'est un hasard on sait
depuis maintenant une dizaine de jours
que ce texte ne sera pas adopté
aujourd'hui c'était le vote solennelle
mais les jeux mais les jeux mais les
jeux sont faits donc il y a pas de lien
avec avec le 49 ans
je vois deux problèmes de problèmes à ce
rejet le premier vous en avez parlé déjà
c'est vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
européens puisque nous sommes membres de
la zone euro une union économique et
monétaire dans laquelle la France est
rentrée souverainement par référendum
maastrichi a 30 ans
et cette union économique et monétaire
c'est notamment renforcé en 2012 lorsque
François Hollande était président de la
République et que le parti de monsieur
Brun était au pouvoir avec le pack
budgétaire européen et qui a renforcé
les dispositions de la loi de
programmation des finances des finances
publiques
des Finances à l'époque et maintenant
président de la Cour des comptes a
d'ailleurs rappelé en commission des
financiers à un an qu'il était important
que la France est une loi de
programmation on peut être contre le
contenu mais on peut aussi faire en
sorte que cette loi sa voté premier
problème le deuxième c'est que ce n'est
pas que par rapport à Bruxelles qu'on a
une loi de programmation des finances
publiques c'est d'abord pour les
Français c'est d'abord pour le
fonctionnement de nos administrations
puisque ça donne des trajectoires ça
donne des outils de contrôle au
parlementaire et donc sans cet outil en
réalité on prive le Parlement et on
prive les administrations d'un pilotage
donc c'est dommage parce que c'est un
texte qui n'aurait pas dû faire l'objet
d'une tractation politique parce qu'on a
deux lignes des conséquences donc vous
connaissez voilà Bruxelles ne va pas
dire on n'a pas les éléments et donc on
vous n'ouvre pas les vannes de la
relance ça c'est c'est exclu c'est
scénario là il va y avoir une discussion
enfin pour le moment d'ailleurs
mais il y aura des discussions avec
Bruxelles on va être le seul pays de la
zone euro qui n'aura pas de loi
progression publique franchement c'est
la fout mal ça la fout mal fait les bras
peut-être content de ce coup politique
on affaiblissez pas notre pays là
pardonnez-moi très bien alors d'abord la
loi de programmation de finance publique
vous avez raison ça existe depuis 2008
si obligatoire dans un classement
européen depuis 2012 on ne les a jamais
respectés on les a absolument jamais
respecté ce sont des chiffons de papier
qui servent ensuite à les faire une
prière païenne devant la Commission
européenne ensuite vous savez que ça
résulte d'un traité qui avait adopté
après
qui prévoit des sanctions c'est
l'article 8 de ce traité qui n'ont
jamais été respectées ce même traité
prévoit qu'on doit revenir un équilibre
de défi structurels à 0,5% du Pipe cet
article 3 on ne l'a non plus jamais
respecté alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire aujourd'hui quand il faut réviser
réviser toutes ces règles la France oui
doit réduire c'est difficile nous ne
sommes favorables à la réduction des
déficits et la personne qui a le plus
aggravé les déficites dans notre pays il
s'appelle Emmanuel Macron il a réduit
les moyens de l'État supprimer l'ISF la
crise sanitaire est passée par la moi je
pense et là nous continuons d'ailleurs à
dégrader les finances publiques nous
supprimons la CVAE personne n'avait
jamais demandé la contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises
qui touche les entreprises et qui
bénéficient aux collectivité nous la
supprimons nous avons supprimé la
redevance audiovisée
on s'assoit dessus on renégocie moi je
crois qu'il faut aujourd'hui d'abord se
poser la question de des besoins
économiques du pays la crise est devant
nous elle n'est pas derrière nous on
voit bien aujourd'hui avec les problèmes
énergétiques que nous avons avec la
croissance mondiale qui ralentit un
tiers du monde sera en récession l'année
prochaine et donc aujourd'hui aggraver
la situation des dépenses publiques en
réduisant fortement les dépenses
publiques et bien ça amènerait davantage
de crises ensuite il faut qu'on ait un
débat sur la dette et moi je crois qu'il
faut isoler notre dette issue des
mesures covid et au niveau européens on
va on va venir on reste 2 secondes sur
ce qui s'est passé et puis on va venir
sur ce qu'on
devrait pour maîtriser nos dépenses et
peut-être changer un peu les règles du
jeu marvinho ce qui s'est passé ce soir
c'est grave ou pas
c'est pas plus grave que ça dirons-nous
mais c'est quand même représentatif du
fait que Monsieur rappelle que il y a un
traité qui a été signé et qu'on peut
s'asseoir dessus et que de toute façon
on ne respecte jamais nos engagements et
effectivement je vous ai apporté un
graphique pour vous montrer un petit peu
de programmation rouge là très bien on
va regarder ça ensemble qui montre que
en gros les lois de programmation
effectivement ne sont jamais jamais
respecté mais dans des proportions là
c'est des trajectoires voyez les
pointillés c'est ce qu'on aurait dû
faire et puis en très plein c'est ce
qu'on a fait en termes de réduction du
déficit donc en fait ce n'est jamais
respecté aussi parce qu'il y a eu
plusieurs crises mais ce qu'on voit
c'est que la prochaine loi de
programmation crise financière crise
sanitaire voilà mais cette loi de
programmation effectivement elle on
pouvait dire elle était d'une certaine
façon assez ambitieuse sur la sur la
maîtrise des dépenses sans être
austéritaire le problème c'est qu'on ne
sait pas du tout comment on va y
parvenir les objectifs qui sont fixés
dedans sont à mon sens assez irréalistes
parce que effectivement il y a beaucoup
de baisse d'impôts qui ne sont pas
forcément très financés donc on ne peut
pas dire de l'autre côté c'est de
l'austérité alors justement on y va
Françoise bienvenue à vous je rappelle
que vous êtes économiste à l'ofco je
vous propose de regarder ce sujet et
signé Marco polonais puis je vous
redonne la parole juste après au-delà de
ce vote de cet après-midi la France
a-t-elle vraiment les moyens de revenir
aux 3% de déficit en 5 ans regarde
c'était une promesse de campagne en mars
dernier le candidat Emmanuel Macron fixé
un objectif budgétaire on commence à
rembourser la dette à compter de 2026
conformément aux engagements pris suite
au rapport à tui et on commence à passer
sous la barre des 3% à partir de 27 un
déficit sous les 3% du PIB comment
atteindre cet objectif d'ici 2027 le
gouvernement veut supprimer des niches
fiscales mais aussi lutter contre la
fraude autre volonté concentrer ses
efforts sur l'état en instaurant par
exemple une baisse des dépenses de
fonctionnement pour les collectivités
territoriales des mesures et une
trajectoire financière pas assez
contraignante pour le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques le projet de loi de
programmation n'inscrit pas de retour
rapide vers l'objectif d'équilibre des
finances publiques à moyen terme
l'inflexion de la trajectoire de la
dette est limitée et tardive alors même
que les hypothèses de croissance sont
optimistes alors les prévisions du
gouvernement sont-elles trop optimistes
B valable sur 1% de croissance pour
l'année 2023 une estimation supérieure à
celle de la Banque de France et de
l'OCDE qui s'attendent à 0,6% de
croissance en cause notamment la flambée
des prises énergétiques amplifiée par la
guerre en Ukraine l'activité tricolore
marque le pas de quoi faire plonger la
trajectoire budgétaire dans l'inconnu le
gouvernement a plutôt sous-estimé malgré
les les les alertes multipliées par les
organisations patronales sur ce risque
de faillite en cascade le discours du
plein d'emploi hélas va sans doute être
très bousculée parce qu'il se passe en
ce moment et les nuages noirs
s'accumulent pour le Fond Monétaire
International l'économie mondiale serait
au bord de la récession en Europe cette
récession pourrait toucher l'Allemagne
dès 2023 selon l'OCDE la première
économie de la zone euro
François girolf on entend des mots qui
voilà font froid dans le dos quand même
le mot de récession là ça c'est un mot
prononcé par le FMI on va voir selon les
pays en Europe qui est impacté ou pas
par une chute du produit intérieur brut
là c'est plus de la croissance de la
croissance négative vous à la FCE vous
avez fait un rapport de prévision sur
l'inflation sur le pouvoir d'achat qui
va continuer à baisser dans les mois qui
viennent est-ce qu'on peut réduire les
dépenses publiques dans un contexte
économique aussi incertain alors je
pense que ça va être effectivement
difficile
les prévisions de croissance du
gouvernement à mon avis sont
effectivement très optimistes 1% par an
pour 2023 c'est vraiment très très
optimiste il y a un scénario de la
Banque de France
mais disons qu'ils se repose sur des
hypothèses très optimistes qui très
probablement ne vont pas être remplies
il y a même une possibilité je pense une
récession en France en tout cas la
Banque de France
l'envisage et je pense de plus en plus
d'économistes prévisionnistes envisage
en 2023 pour pour 2023 des 2023 puisque
on a des nuages qui s'annonçaient à
l'horizon on a l'industrie allemande qui
est de plus en plus en difficulté on a
des difficultés de plus en plus dans
l'industrie française
a priori il y a des dispositifs qu'on va
commencer à débrancher un petit peu ma
au niveau français c'est-à-dire que le
bouquet est tarifaire va être un petit
peu moins généreuse qui je pense est une
bonne chose mais les prix de
l'électricité du gaz vont augmenter de
15% à la rentrée donc ça va diminuer le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages qui va aussi
être quelque chose de mauvais pour la
croissance donc il y a plein de choses
qui font que les voilà ça va être un peu
compliqué l'année prochaine et cela
d'autant plus que ce discours là un peu
churchillien qui disent attention ça va
être dur personne ne tient pour
l'instant pour quelle raison il faut pas
effrayer les Français il faut les
rassurer c'est ça le contexte malvinho
comment vous comprenez au fond que il y
a un décalage entre les une révision les
conjonctures à venir et au fond l'état
d'esprit ambiants des de nos gouvernants
parce que quand de Bercy est d'abord le
budget c'est des mois avant la
présentation de la copie budgétaire donc
il y a des informations qui n'ont pas et
puis après effectivement si dégrade leur
prévision ils sont obligés d'afficher un
déficit plus important et donc c'est un
peu problématique en termes de signal en
ce moment mais le président de la
République a quand même dit c'est la fin
de l'abondance il a quand même dit il va
falloir se préparer à d'éventuelles
coupures si jamais l'hiver est vraiment
trop rigoureux si on n'arrive pas à
rebrancher nos centrales nucléaires qui
ont des problèmes de corrosion et qui
sont en maintenant donc je crois que le
discours est quand même en train
d'infuser enfin en tout cas il faudrait
qu'il infuse et c'est vrai ça va être
compliqué le gouvernement s'apprête
demain à annoncer un dispositif d'aide
aux entreprises parce que il sait que
les entreprises vont avoir beaucoup de
mal à payer leurs factures d'électricité
là je rappelle que les entreprises ont
des contrats
électricité et de gaz qui peuvent qui
peuvent être appris fixes depuis
plusieurs années et qui arrivent souvent
à la fin de l'année pour simplifier à
échéance et donc là les prix les
entreprises vont non seulement avoir
assumer des hausses de salaire éventuels
des prix de l'énergie qui augmentent et
donc là les marges des entreprises qui
pour l'instant se tenaient bien risque
de se dégrader et là on rentre dans une
dans une spirale effectivement qui est
compliqué alors c'est vous qui êtes aux
affaires pour la majorité ma chronique
Charles season stool qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous devez faire est-ce
que c'est pas le moment de mettre en
suspens les objectifs de réduction de
dépenses est-ce qu'on peut se permettre
de trouver de l'argent et où dans un
contexte où on sent bien que les
Français même s'ils vont devoir se
serrer la ceinture la sobriété on l'a
comprise elle arrive quand ça sera pas
des coupures il risque d'y avoir
d'autres conséquences des conséquences
en termes d'activité économique même je
pense qu'il faut dire c'est que quand
même depuis
plus de deux ans maintenant bientôt 3
début de la crise sanitaire on est dans
une période d'une instabilité
qui n'avait pas été vu en tout cas sur
une échelle de temps extrêmement courte
ça a été les montagnes russes y compris
du point de vue économique économique
pardon moi je me souviens des débats
qu'on pouvait avoir en 2018 en 2019 je
travaille à l'époque au ministère de
l'économie et des finances on avait des
taux on avait des taux négatifs c'était
là pour le coup l'abondance
de l'argent c'était très simple pour
beaucoup pour beaucoup de Français de
souscrire
2019 commençait à alerter sur une
surchauffe c'était les termes et ensuite
il y a eu le la crise de la crise
sanitaire confinement effondrement du de
la croissance
redémarrage extrêmement rapide de la
croissance en France aussi ce qui montre
qu'on est quand même on a un tissu
économiste extrêmement robuste je viens
d'une circonscription plutôt rurale et
périurbaine avec beaucoup de PME
beaucoup d'entreprises industrielles
tout ça ça milieu de l'Alsace ça ça
tient ils ont ils ont tenu et d'ailleurs
moi les discussions
les demandes qui émanent du monde
économique c'est d'abord d'avoir des
discours je dirais de clarté je ne pense
pas que le gouvernement fasse preuve
d'excès d'optimisme depuis plusieurs
plusieurs mois sur le sujet économique
les propos de Bruno Le Maire à la fin
juin lorsqu'il a parlé de la fameuse
côte d'alerte ou de la fin de
l'abondance ou d'ailleurs et mettaient
même beaucoup critiqués je pense qu'il a
ils ont le gouvernement fait preuve de
lucidité ensuite c'est de fixer des
objectifs c'est pour ça que je reviens à
cette loi de programmation des finances
publiques on a une trajectoire et puis
surtout de répondre aux difficultés
importantes immédiates marques Vignol a
dit demain il y aura des annonces du
gouvernement
et donc tout ça je termine par là
ensuite je vous rends la parole ce qui
n'a pas été dit tout à l'heure dans le
reportage c'est
difficultés en situation de fortes
tensions et il y a besoin de dépenses
pour accompagner notamment les
entreprises vous en parliez pour
affronter la crise et aussi accompagner
accompagner les Français alors la
dépense comment on la réduit moi je
pense qu'effectivement il y a des
réductions à faire et toutes les
dépenses d'ailleurs public ne sont pas
nécessairement des dépenses qui ont un
impact sur la croissance on a
aujourd'hui effectivement une
administration administrante qu'on peut
probablement réduire on a des simples
les macronistes là-dessus réforme de
l'État collectivité locale et
pardonnez-moi mais taxer les super
profits ça n'a pas d'impact négatif sur
la croissance rétablir l'impôt sur la
fortune cela n'a pas d'impact négatif
sur la croissance aujourd'hui on est
toujours incapable d'évaluer l'effet de
l'impact de la suppression de l'impôt
sur la fortune on a bien vu que ça n'a
eu aucun effet il y a un certain nombre
de recettes qu'il faut créer on peut pas
aujourd'hui
qui rentreraient dans les caisses avec
ces mesures tout de même
là tout si vous additionnez
sur les super profits c'est 7 milliards
au niveau européen ça c'est beaucoup
mais celle qui est européenne est en
deçà de ce que nous pouvons proposer et
qui serait acceptable donc encore une
fois il faut réarmer notre état avec des
recettes solides et il faut aussi je
crois réduire les dépenses qui ne
touchent pas au quotidien des Français
la question finalement c'est celle de
des impôts est-ce que marvinho vous
pensez que ce gouvernement ne pourra pas
faire autrement à un moment ou un autre
que d'augmenter les impôts pas forcément
des particuliers mais peut-être de
certaines entreprises la question va se
poser mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que dans la bouche des politiques ce
n'est jamais le moment de couper les
dépenses quand ça va bien mais vous
rendez vous compte c'est pas le moment
de couper les dépenses quand ça va mal
c'est pas le moment de coupler les
dépenses que disent les économistes
c'est qu'il faut pas trop couper les
dépenses dans les périodes où ça va mal
alors là c'est une crise dont on peut
espérer que c'est l'inflation importée
on peut espérer qu'elle va avec la fin
de la guerre
d'austérité incroyable dans cette loi de
programmation il y a une stabilité des
dépenses en réalité c'est à dire qu'on
fait un peu moins en volume c'est-à-dire
qu'on suit l'inflation quand même les
dépenses suivent l'inflation et en gros
on les on les on les stabilise en terme
par exemple de fonctionnaires c'est
qu'on n'en bouge pas de nouveau
fonctionnaires même si on reprit d'une
année sur l'autre on augmente les
dépenses publiques uniquement pour que
l'euro qu'on a mis l'année précédente va
être la même chose que l'année suivante
donc c'est déjà beaucoup plus ambitieux
que d'autres années mais ce n'est pas
non plus une austérité débridée voilà
donc il faut il faut savoir
l'inflation de prêt il faut faire des
choix dans la dépense publique regarder
la qualité des dépenses publiques et
donc faire des choix ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que si on veut privilégier
les dépenses d'avenir réindustrialiser
permettre aux entreprises d'être plus
compétitives il faut regarder dans les
systèmes qui ont des déficits et on voit
que la France dépense beaucoup plus pour
ses retraites par exemple que ses
voisins européens et en partie parce que
le système est plus généreux parce que
les Français passent plus de temps à la
retraite qu'ils ont un taux d'emploi des
seniors qui bien inférieur à la moyenne
des autres pays et donc si on veut faire
des économies mais il y a des économies
à faire d'autant qu'il a des déficits ce
système de retraite
il y a une question qui va se poser
aussi c'est le coût de la transition
écologique et énergétique parce qu'il y
a énormément d'investissement à venir en
2050 2035 l'État va devoir investir
massivement pour accompagner cette
transition dans ce contexte c'est
compatible
il me semble que ça va être difficile
parce que là déjà on a énormément de
dépenses qui sont prévues comme j'ai dit
il y a quand même enfin c'est quand même
très optimiste de prévoir qu'on va
revenir au plein emploi comme vous
l'avez dit en 2027 on sait pas très bien
comment on va arriver à 5% de chômage
comme ça fait un moment qu'on n'a pas
réussi pour vous cette promesse n'est
pas tenable c'est pas qu'elle est enfin
je vais être optimiste et je veux que la
France réussisse et je souhaite que que
le gouvernement réussisse mais c'est
vrai que j'ai tendance à être un peu
prudent par rapport à cette hypothèse en
tout cas c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
jamais observé
y compris les services de l'État
d'ailleurs ont eu du mal à faire cette
hypothèse dans l'ensemble des documents
administratifs qui ont été présentés
donc c'est quand même quelque chose
auquel les économistes sont du mal à
croire
les réformes comme la réforme des
retraites il y a pas beaucoup d'autres
options en fait
idéalement on arriverait à
réindustrialiser à augmenter la
production la productivité donc ça ça se
serait le cas où on aurait pas besoin
donc effectivement le gouvernement je
pense devient peut-être un petit peu
moins optimiste du point de vue de la
productivité de la nouvelle croissance
qu'on va pouvoir obtenir et veut faire
travailler les gens plus pour pour que
le people augmente et qu'on puisse
rembourser cet argent je pense que c'est
une des stratégies que le gouvernement
veut avoir
une dépense qui nous coûte aussi très
chère c'est la charge de la dette et
vous avez pu voir que cette année la
charge la dette explose pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que les taux
augmentent mais c'est pas à cause de ça
en fait elle la charge
parce que la Banque centrale européenne
pour piloter les choses face à
l'inflation fait augmenter les
pénétration
chaque année mais ce qui fait exploser
la facture cette année c'est la mauvaise
gestion de ce gouvernement qui a
consenti à des empreintes toxiques on a
11% de notre dette qui aujourd'hui
indexée sur l'inflation alors ça pardon
c'est totalement
11% de notre dette et c'est aujourd'hui
un excès sur l'inflation c'est 4 % en
Allemagne et donc ça nous coûte cette
année 16 milliards de plus dans d'autres
charges la dette pour
non mais quel actif toxique
11% de notre dette ce sont des
obligations dont le rendement en fait
est indexé sur l'inflation c'est-à-dire
que plus l'inflation augmente plus vous
devez rembourser beaucoup et on a été
assez gourmand en fait sur ces actifs
durant les dernières années ce qui fait
que par exemple en Allemagne seulement
4% de la dette est avec ses sur
l'inflation nous c'est 11% et donc ça
donne fait une facture qui est
astronomique on a 15 milliards de plus
effectivement de pendant des années
d'avoir des obligations qui coûtaient
moins cher aujourd'hui ça nous coûte un
peu plus cher mais très cher l'inflation
plus que l'électricité progresse aussi
et normalement quand il y a de
l'inflation les recettes doivent suivre
alors la question c'est est-ce que une
inflation importée ou pas là on se
retrouve dans une crise d'inflation
importée je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
mettre sur le dos des obligations
indexées le problème de dette publique
de la France elle explose cette année
c'est deux fois plus de la justice quand
même donc il y a un vrai sujet un mot
politique économique le rôle important
de la Banque centrale européenne
elle augmente les taux la raison de le
faire en même temps augmenter les taux
s'arrangerait la dette et donc c'est un
cercle vicieux comme on comment sortir
non mais les grandes banques centrales
dont la BCE ont effectivement augmentent
les taux depuis plusieurs mois c'est
pour freiner freiner l'inflation on voit
bien que pour le moment ce qui impacte
directement nos concitoyens également
nos entreprises c'est l'inflation donc
c'est pour ça que progressivement la BCE
augmente les taux vous parlez de la BCE
moi je profite quand même de ce débat
pour dire à quel point nous avons pu
mesurer à l'occasion de la dernière
crise que le rot était une protection
pour notre économie pour la France et
pour pour les Français moi je repense
encore au débat qu'on pouvait qu'il
pouvait y avoir dans certains partis
politiques qui sont pas présents autour
de la table je pense notamment à
l'extrême droite
il y a il y a il y a quelques années ils
ont fait fausse route ils se sont
trompés l'euro a été une protection
incroyable pour notre économie je n'ose
même pas imaginer ce qu'aurait pu être
la gestion de la crise en 2020 et en
2021 si nous avions pas cette monnaie
commune et si nous avions pas eu cette
capacité à emprunter au niveau de ça
pour conclure on a une monnaie
suffisamment forte qui nous a protégé de
la crise en même temps on a des voisins
comme l'Italie qui craignent quasiment
une attaque sur leurs dettes donc ça
peut peut-être nous arriver aussi
l'Italie est protégé par l'euro c'est
vrai que là on a un déficit commercial
La France a un décide commerciale énorme
en particulier si on comprend la facture
énergétique qui est plus grand en fait
que celui qu'on avait en 1981 quand il y
a eu la spéculation sur le front et
qu'on a décidé de d'évaluer le front
donc effectivement dans la même
situation on peut comparer dans un cas
on a une crise de chances et là par
définition on peut pas avoir de crise de
change donc effectivement et donc la
raison c'est que notre déficit
commercial est pensé par nos partenaires
européens qui eux ont plutôt des surplus
commerciaux même si en ce moment ils
sont en train de diminuer très fortement
donc effectivement dans ce sens là
l'euro est une protection en même temps
il faut faire un peu attention parce
qu'il nous permet aussi de nous des
industrialiser sans qu'on s'en rende
compte nécessairement et donc il faut
faire un petit peu attention la
dynamique depuis depuis
l'aggravation du déficit commercial
vous aurez le mot de la fin Marc Vigneau
ce qui est sûr c'est que l'exemple
britannique nous montre que quand un
gouvernement fait un peu n'importe quoi
avec sa politique fiscale il peut être
très vite mis en danger parce que il
peut y avoir tout d'un coup un
retournement des marchés qui perdent
confiance et donc là c'était une
politique fiscale axée sur des baisses
d'impôts massives d'impôt sur les
sociétés pour les plus riches etc et
donc ça peut déstabiliser un pays on
voit à quel point ça a été le cas il y
avait quand même la première ministre
qui a été qui a qui a été renvoyé enfin
qui est parti et qui a dû laisser sa à
quelqu'un d'autre merci pour cet
avertissement voilà espérons que notre
pays soit prémunite ce scénario quelque
chose me dit qu'on va continuer à parler
de tous ces sujets dans les semaines et
les mois à venir merci à vous d'avoir
participé à ce débat on va accueillir à
présent notre grand témoin il est
l'auteur du livre dont tout le monde
parle il faut dire que son histoire
mondiale des riches chez plomb sera
point nommé en plein débat sur la
taxation des super profits et sur la
rémunération des grands patrons
radiographie des plus grosses fortunes
de la planète vous allez le voir elles
sont très différentes les unes des
autres fabrices d'Almeida nous rejoint
bonsoir Fabrice c'est un plaisir de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau alors
commençons tout de suite par cette
question qui vous est posée par par ce
sujet est-ce que vous pensez que le
seuil de tolérance des Français étant
pas être franchie face aux inégalités
qui deviennent de plus en plus criante
alors il y a un changement qui est clair
je sais pas si c'est un seuil de rupture
ou de tolérance par rapport à
l'inégalité mais il y a une chose qui
est claire c'est que sur le front des
salaires je crois que maintenant il y a
mécontentement assez universel et que
beaucoup de gens avec l'inflation
réclament des augmentations et donc
comme il y a assez réclamations comme il
y a ces demandes fatalement à un moment
ou un autre ça devrait permettre de
remonter le bas de la société peut-être
de réduire les inégalités avec cette
au-dessus demande d'exemplarité la
France est ce pays où cette question des
riches est ultra sensible
urticante on le voit tous les jours le
tweet de Patrick pouyanet sur sa
rémunération comme patron total a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre aujourd'hui
c'est le montant
faramineux du contrat de Mbappé révélé
par Le Parisien plus de 600 millions
d'euros de contrats pourquoi nous en
particulier c'est si difficile cette
question là est-ce que c'est l'héritage
révolutionnaire ou ça remonte à plus
loin je crois que vous avez entièrement
raison il y a chez nous l'idée que les
riches c'est pas seulement la question
de l'aisance financière chez nous et
c'est une des options que j'examine dans
le livre on a l'idée que les riches
comme dans l'ancien français c'était le
sens que le mot Ricky avait dans
l'ancien français les riches sont des
puissants ils ont des pouvoirs
particuliers et donc partant de là elle
juge de privilège or vous l'avez dit
nous sommes le pays où l'on a aboli les
privilèges la nuit du 4 août 1789 et
donc il y a quelque chose dans notre ADN
national qui fait que même si on peut
admettre l'excellence on a toujours au
bout d'un moment l'impression qu'il faut
empêcher les personnes d'avoir des
choses
supplémentaires par rapport aux autres
les riches les ultras riches
d'aujourd'hui
sont redevenus comme
l'étymologie du mot les puissants
d'aujourd'hui alors vous êtes attaqués
dans cette formidable enquête historique
à ceux qui ont la capacité d'agir à
l'échelle mondiale pourquoi eux qui
sont-ils combien sont-ils c'est vraiment
un groupe de super riches là je veux
dire je prends je voulais vraiment c'est
difficile de définir les riches il y en
a qui disent que c'est plus deux trois
fois le SMIC il y en a qui disent que
c'est 4000 euros 5000 euros les Français
eux-mêmes disent plutôt 5000 euros quand
on les interroge dans les sondages donc
ça c'est des définitions statistiques
mais moi ce que je voulais savoir c'est
qui a fait quoi dans l'histoire est-ce
que c'est vrai que les riches dominent
l'histoire où est-ce qu'au contraire par
moment ils sont frappés par l'histoire
de plein fouet par exemple quand il y a
la Révolution bolchevique les Russes
sont éclats les Russes éclatent
casse toute l'aristocratie et tous les
riches des entreprises donc d'un coup il
y a un pays sans riche en 1917 et ça va
continuer ça va être un modèle qui va
faire peur à tout le monde qu'est-ce qui
se passe quand il y a une guerre la
Première Guerre mondiale est-ce que les
riches dominent la scène ou est-ce qu'on
contracte ils sont contraints par le
peuple et ce qu'on constate c'est qu'aux
États-Unis en France on adopte l'impôt
sur le revenu on le met en place et les
riches acceptent même de le payer c'est
quand même quelque chose d'assez fou
imaginez quand on a créé l'impôt sur le
revenu les riches ont accepté de même de
le payer il y avait pas d'inspecteur des
contributions à l'époque et pas
l'inspecteur des impôts mais ils étaient
patriotes et ils pensaient que c'était
essentiel alors vous êtes attaqué donc
assez super riche d'ailleurs c'est
vertigine il y a les maîtres du monde et
les nouveaux maîtres du monde notamment
les dirigeants des ce qu'on appelle les
gafas ou les les gafams d'ailleurs à E5
les chiffres donnent le vertige il
concentre une valeur qui est comparable
au PIB de la France de l'Allemagne donc
c'est gigantesque ils sont concentrés ou
c'est dans le monde dans le monde le
pays qui a le plus de milliardaires
parce que c'est de ça dont on parle on
parle de gens qui sont capables de
mobiliser des centaines de millions pour
faire de la création industrielle pour
lancer un nouveau modèle de vêtements de
voiture ou une nouvelle arme ou un
nouveau médicament qui peut être positif
ou négatif donc on parle vraiment des
très grands milliardaires la Chine est
le pays qui en compte le plus il y en a
plus de 2200 pratiquement 2300 sans
doute à la fin de l'année quand on fera
le décompte on sera à 2400 2500 plus que
les États-Unis qui derrière compte
environ aussi 2000 milliardaires en
Europe le pays qui concentre le plus de
milliardaires en chiffres c'est
l'Allemagne derrière en fait par
habitant par habitant la France si on
fait non c'est les Suisses mais il y a
des pays comme la Suède où il y a
étonnamment presque autant de
milliardaires qu'en France une
quarantaine en France on en a 43 donc
c'est vraiment
concentré mais pas seulement dans le
monde occidental si on voulait réfléchir
à la concentration en fait les
milliardaires sont quand même souvent
dans des grandes villes c'est pour ça
quand on regarde au Nigeria ben
effectivement ils sont Lagos des gens
comme ALIKO Dangote qui est une des plus
grandes fortunes mondiales et qui la
plus grande fortune africaine ce qui est
intéressant c'est évidemment de
comprendre comment elles se sont
constituées à travers l'histoire le
tournant c'est la révolution
industrielle le 19e siècle c'est la fin
d'une époque la fin des rentiers et
celle des aristocrates s'écrouent en
Allemagne ses Schneider au Creusot en
France c'est le tournant majeur de
l'émergence de ces grandes fortunes
l'espèce de d'égalité qui avait eu entre
je suis un noble je possède beaucoup de
terres et je suis donc une grande
fortune mais avec l'industrie il y a des
gens qui n'étaient pas d'une grande
naissance il y a des gens qui n'avaient
pas forcément beaucoup d'argent qui sont
mis à créer de véritables empires vous
avez parlé des géants de l'acier il y a
les deux vins d'ailes et les Schneider
les petits saints les groupes les vikers
en Angleterre donc des gens qui ont des
Forges énormes et qui vont devenir
bientôt des géants de la technologie de
l'époque qui s'appliquent à l'armement
la fameuse le fameux les trains aussi
enfin britannique qui va jouer un rôle
très important en 1860 et qui va tout
permettre en fait la libéralisation des
marchés la libre circulation des
capitaux le personnage le plus
emblématique de cette fin du 19e siècle
c'est l'Américain on peut voir son sa
photo John dit John Davidson Rockefeller
premier milliardaire de l'époque
contemporaine énorme fortune gigantesque
fortune on pense qu'en dollars constants
il aurait aujourd'hui le double de la
fortune de
alors ça c'est vraiment à peine j'ai lu
ça et il est en plus riche en dollars
constants qu'un Jeff Bezos mais mais il
est pratiquement le seul de son espèce à
son époque au bout du au tournant du
siècle vers les années 1900 ils seront
trois quatre comme ça mais c'est très
différent d'aujourd'hui ou vous avez vu
on a on a compté on a pratiquement 10000
15000 milliardaires à l'échelle mondiale
donc on est on est vraiment avec un
personnage qui a une échelle de fortune
énorme dans l'histoire qui concentre
d'une industrie qui est l'industrie
pétrolière dans ses mains à un moment où
le pétrole sert avant tout à illuminer
et au moment où commence à émerger le
moteur explosion on est dans les années
1900 et donc ça va compléter sa fortune
il va devenir une très grande fortune
grâce à l'automobile alors on va aller
vite parce qu'évidemment on n'a pas le
temps d'aborder toutes les périodes vous
parlez des guerres de la deuxième guerre
mondiale c'est très intéressant de voir
qui s'enrichit qui au contraire nous
enrichit pas sous le nazisme et puis il
y a après-guerre alors là c'est la
financiarisation de l'économie c'est
l'air de la jet-set Hollywood les
premiers jet Marcel Dassault le jet
privé et puis il y a le tourné un des
années 80 donc plus proche de nous et là
les riches basculent dans le star system
notamment grâce à un journal qui va
faire beaucoup le magazine Forbes
expliquez-nous ce qui est très frappant
c'est que au départ être riche c'est une
situation c'est pas un statut social or
avec les classements qui se mettent en
place progressivement le but un certain
nombre de personnes va être de rentrer
dans les classements parce que à partir
du moment où on est identifié comme
grande fortune ou encore milliardaire et
bien il y a des propositions
supplémentaires qui interviennent ou il
y a comment dirais un avis de fiabilité
qui est donné à la société je prends
l'exemple dans le livre d'un
multimillionnaire asiatique enfin
français français vietnamien
franco-vietamiens qui a voulu rentrer
dans le classement de challenge qui est
le grand classement français parce qu'à
un moment donné lui il est champion de
poker il veut continuer à faire des très
grandes affaires sur le secteur
immobilier et donc sa crédibilité c'est
d'être dans le classement et dans la
même logique Kylie Jenner dont on a vu
l'image s'afficher qui est une jeune
Américaine de la famille Kardashian elle
va vouloir à tout prix être dans le
classement forts pourquoi parce que son
objectif c'est qu'on dise qu'elle est
milliardaire et que donc la société
qu'elle a créé qui fabrique des
cosmétiques est une parfaite réussite
elle fait ça en fait pour pouvoir vendre
son entreprise à une plus grande encore
elle va mentir sur la réalité exacte du
montant de sa fortune elle a été très
habile et qu'elle a les gens de force
qui très très vite ont corrigé le tir on
dit bah finalement il y a quelqu'un de
plus rigide alors Fabrice je vais vous
montrer parce que ils sont très
différents c'est ce que vous dites aussi
il y a des vertueux il y a des gens
beaucoup plus vicieux même regardez on a
vous la préparer une mosaïque de
milliardaires Jeffrey Kylie jainer on
vient d'en parler c'est le milliardaire
qui a profite de son argent et de sa
richesse pour fasciner des gamines
mineurs et les violets ou les
transformer en prostituées
on en a beaucoup parlé mais vous dites
bien d'ailleurs dans votre livre qu'il
crée de la richesse qu'il crée de
l'emploi qu'il travaille énormément
il est un personnage qui tient vraiment
c'est ce que je pensais qui tient
vraiment en main notre avenir Bill Gates
qui donne sa fortune alors là on est
vraiment dans l'amertume le plus riche
propriétaire terrien américain
c'est-à-dire c'est quand même très
frappant que quelqu'un qui a fait sa
fortune dans la Silicon Valley qui a
avec Microsoft couvert la planète de
logiciel et bien place son argent dans
la terre avec notamment un très très
grand ranch voilà donc il a aussi cette
cette dimension là un dernier petit mot
peut-être Bernard Arnault on le connaît
d'ailleurs vous expliquer vraiment qu'il
a il a énormément
investi fait des efforts justement pour
toujours garder le contact avec le
terrain peut-être Oprah Winfrey
peut-être celle qu'on a classé comme la
femme noire la plus riche du monde mais
c'est une réussite personnelle
exceptionnelle mais c'est elle est toute
petite en termes d'argent c'est 2
milliards et demi par rapport à un
hélico Dangote qui est beaucoup plus
riche qu'elle et qui sait offusqué qu'on
ose la placer comme la plus riche femme
noire un mot sur Arnaud je le trouve
extraordinaire parce que effectivement
il y a le côté fortune mais il y a aussi
le côté conservatoire des savoir-faire
français donc c'est toujours quelque
chose que j'aime mettre en avant vous
avez compris c'est passionnant on aurait
pu continuer longtemps on peut ouvrir
beaucoup de tiroirs à la fois historique
contemporain histoire
mondiale le vrai pouvoir il l'incarne
c'est aux éditions plomb vous restez
avec moi merci d'Almeida c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ce soir l'histoire du jour de
l'assemblée et si Stéphanie Despierre on
va voir d'abord pardonnez-moi ça c'est
Céline braque bien sûr on va
l'accueillir Céline qui va nous révéler
le baromètre odoxal du mois d'octobre
ensuite Stéphanie Despierre pour
l'histoire du jour la voici Stéphanie à
l'écran ce soir les députés et la
corrida et puis la féministe Léa
chamboncelle pourquoi les hommes sont
toujours plus riches que les femmes ça
va vous intéresser Fabrice j'en suis sûr
bonsoir mesdames et bienvenue sur ce
plateau Céline on commence avec vous
baromètre doxa du mois d'octobre pour
les chaînes parlementaires qui
s'intéressent au pouvoir d'achat en
berne des Français et à ses conséquences
sur l'exécutif on va voir ça avec la
hausse des prix qui affecte lourdement
les Français 96% d'entre eux sont
impactés par des pertes de pouvoir
d'achat c'est colossal oui on est en
fait dans ces perceptions on est sur des
chiffres bien plus élevés que les
chiffres officiels en fait relevés par
l'INSEE c'est une hausse de 11 points de
cette perception de baisse de pouvoir
d'achat de la part des Français par
rapport à juin donc vous voyez c'est
assez rare qu'on mesure des des
augmentations aussi fortes en si peu de
temps et ce que l'on voit c'est que les
Français comment ceci à modifier leur
mode de consommation ce qui nous dit
c'est qu'il modifie leur comportement
alors principalement
dans en matière d'énergie donc on a 67%
qui nous disent on modifie notre
consommation en matière d'énergie mais
on voit aussi que les proportions sont
importantes en termes de consommation de
bien de consommation pour les loisirs
les vacances etc en tout c'est 83% de
gens qui nous disent avoir au moins
modifié un de ces comportements et là
aussi on a des évolutions très très
importantes par rapport à juin puisqu'on
a 10 points de différence par rapport au
mois de juin donc on voit que les
Français font très très attention et
comment ce vraiment à faire des
économies à moins consommer ou à
consommer différemment et c'est dans ce
contexte que les Français c'est aussi un
chiffre du baromètre doxa de d'octobre
estime que l'exécutif n'en fait pas
assez pour pour les protéger à 73% le
gouvernement n'agit pas ou pas
suffisamment pour eux oui c'est-à-dire
que dans les différentes enquêtes on
voyait que les Français considéraient
que
il y avait une action qui était un peu
faible et que quand il se passait des
événements désagréables en l'occurrence
la grève dans les raffineries là le
gouvernement était doublement faible et
n'était pas présent pour faire des
réquisitions auxquelles les Français
étaient favorables la conséquence sur la
popularité du couple exécutif elle est
immédiate et logiquement c'est à dire
que Emmanuel Macron perd trois points en
un mois
il se retrouve à 38% du jugement positif
il est en dessous de sa ligne de
flottaison habituelle qui est de
40%, et celle qui parle plus de points
c'est Elisabeth borne qui avait eu
plutôt du succès à la rentrée et qui est
aujourd'hui à 35% de popularité c'est
très faible une baisse de 6 points et
elle perd beaucoup chez les gens qui
sont politisés de droite comme de gauche
bon et puis c'est vrai que c'est elle
qui est en première ligne en ce moment
et c'est elle qui prend le plus on va
dire de points en moins ou qui prend le
voilà qui baisse le plus tard le plus
les oppositions elle est-ce qu'elle
profite de ce contexte économique
difficile pour les Français alors si on
prend les deux têtes d'opposition
principale Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine
Le Pen et Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui il ne
progresse pas d'un iota il est à 22% de
code d'adhésion ça veut dire que ça le
met en sixième place execo avec Jordan
Bardella dans le classement qu'on fait
des personnalités on a vu qu'en fait le
ces prises de parole très fortes elles
ont plutôt agacé les Français qu'autre
chose cette espèce de surprise
médiatique bon les affaires en plus ce
cadenas Bayou etc ça n'a pas fait
beaucoup de bien à la France insoumise a
contrario Marine Le Pen elle continue à
progresser
elle prend deux points mais c'est la
deuxième personnalité oui juste derrière
l'un des Ronal popularité Philippe et en
fait il s'est passé un renforce un
renversement de situation en 5 ans
puisqu'en 5 ans on était vraiment à
l'envers avec un Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
était beaucoup plus populaire que Marine
Le Pen et beaucoup moins rejeté
aujourd'hui c'est l'inverse il est moins
populaire et il est beaucoup plus rejeté
que Marine Le Pen baromètre doxa signer
Céline braque pour les chaînes
parlementaires pour LCP chaque mois
Marine Le Pen qui profite de la crise ça
vous étonne elle déjà elle joue elle
joue habile à l'Assemblée on l'a vu ces
derniers jours qui dit que quoi qu'il se
passe ça profite à Marine Le Pen vous
souvenez c'est ce qu'on disait depuis
des années et donc c'est un peu le
sentiment
quand on est loin des élections en fait
le regard serait n'est pas tout à fait
le même Stéphanie vous nous emmenez ce
soir pour l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée vers quoi le Sud-Ouest la
corrida il y a une proposition de loi
qui Clive alors ça c'est une évidence
pas forcément le droit de gauche
d'ailleurs je subtil que ça proposition
de loi d'Aymeric Caron qui vise à
interdire la corrida elle sera débattue
en novembre elle divise au sein même de
la majorité Renaissance oui il y a
clairement plusieurs camps alors dans le
premier celui des défenseurs de la
corrida ce sont donc plutôt les députés
du Sud habitant les zones où la
tauromachie et pratiquer
pourquoi on va interdire on va faire une
proposition de loi sur la corrida qui va
s'éteindre toute seule parce que je
pense que dans 10-15 ans il y aura plus
d'afficionados mais c'est quoi cette
France de l'interdiction vous savez dans
les territoires un peu difficiles comme
les miens je pèse mes mots les gens ils
attendent le plus rien de nous et
aujourd'hui en plus on va leur dire que
le dimanche ils pourront pas accéder
cette corrida cette corrida c'est
culturelle alors ensuite il y a les
anticorridas alors au premier rang
Aurore berger la présidente du groupe
Renaissance qui de longue date est
favorable à son interdiction et comme
elle de nombreux autres députés veulent
privilégier la cause animale
c'est un petit peu éculé aujourd'hui de
vouloir faire souffrir des des animaux
par plaisir je pense que très
honnêtement on peut faire de la corrida
autrement et qu'il est pas nécessaire de
les faire souffrir avec des bons dérias
et d'aller jusqu'à la mort en fait c'est
je pense je vois pas pourquoi il y
aurait des exceptions de tradition si je
suis dans l'hémicycle
mais je pense que oui je serai en effet
tout à fait prête à appuyer sur le
bouton en faveur de cette VPL même si
elle vient des insoumis même si elle
vient des insoumides alors c'est une
position qui est loin de faire consensus
même si on est contre la corrida faut-il
voter une proposition des insoumis c'est
l'autre question stratégique celle-ci
qui agite les députés Renaissance les
esprits se sont échauffés ce matin lors
de leur réunion hebdomadaire votée avec
elle et fils et non explique une
responsable du groupe un autre a
carrément mis en garde ses collègues
cela reviendrait à travailler avec
l'extrême gauche et donc à ne pas
respecter la volonté d'Emmanuel Macron
enfin il y a aussi beaucoup d'indécis de
députés qui ne se sentent pas concernés
par la corrida et qui pourrait
s’abstenir en tout cas Aurore berger ne
veut pas tordre le bras c'est par le
menteur alors pour ne fâcher personne le
groupe ne prendra pas de position
officielle il y a comme on dit liberté
de vote donc ça veut dire que il y a une
chance que ce texte ne soit pas du tout
discuté ni adopté
exactement d'abord il n'est pas sûr que
cette proposition puisse aboutir le 24
novembre tout dépend de sa place dans la
niche parlementaire la France insoumise
le groupe n'a qu'une journée dédié dans
l'hémicycle si la corrida n'est pas en
haut de son agenda ce débat pourrait ne
pas avoir lieu jusqu'au bout faute de
temps ensuite il faudrait qu'une
majorité de députés du groupe
présidentiel décide de la soutenir alors
c'est probablement ce qui va se passer
mais pour le moment c'est impossible de
compter et enfin il est difficile de
compter également dans les autres
groupes le rassemblement national comme
Renaissance et divisé et ne donnera pas
de consignes de vote et même au sein de
la nupesse les socialistes et les
communistes ne sont pas tous prêts à
voter cette interdiction d'accord un
gros malaise au sein des différents
groupes sur la sur la corrida on sent
qu'aucun ministre même ne veut aller au
banc défendre la corrida contre aymeric
Caron qui veut qui veut l'interdire mais
moi je trouve ça bien que il laisse la
liberté de vote aux député je trouve que
c'est c'est une chose qui est très
importante justement le choix individuel
sur ce type de question éthique alors
cette chronique à présent de la Fabrice
d'Almeida elle est un peu pour vous dans
la ligne droite de votre ouvrage vous
vous intéressez à l'ouvrage Léa ce soir
de Titou le coq intitulé le couple et
l'argent dans lequel cette féministe
s'attaque à la question fondamentale
pourquoi les hommes sont-ils plus riches
que les femmes effectivement est-ce que
vous avez remarqué Myriam que lorsque
vous allez chez le coiffeur les
prestations que vous payez sont toujours
plus celles que plus cher que celle des
hommes
est-ce que vous avez aussi par ailleurs
vous aussi est-ce que vous avez aussi
remarqué que les femmes se retrouvent
souvent à dépenser beaucoup d'argent
pour répondre aux injonctions qui pèsent
sur elles à savoir acheter des crèmes en
tirer acheter des crème anti-cellulites
anti-socie anti-sola ou pour ceci ou
pour cela oui certes mais pas que il y a
aussi l'inégalité des salaires et ça ça
te perdure effectivement on peut se
demander quand même toujours aujourd'hui
d'écart encore encore en 2022 absolument
en moyenne effectivement et on peut se
poser la question quand même est-ce que
il y a bien une raison qui peu justifier
tout ça donc moi je suis allé chercher
et je n'ai pas trouvé de raison il n'y a
rien qui explique en fait ces inégalités
ces différences de traitement rien qui
n'explique non plus cette paupérisation
en fait des femmes donc dans cette offre
ouvrage très percutant et très très bien
documenté en l'occurrence on apprend
notamment que ces dernières années
l'écart de patrimoine entre les femmes
et les hommes c'est considérablement
creusé passant ainsi de 9 % en 1998 à
16% en 2015 mais on apprend également
que la conjugalisation de l'impôt sur le
revenu et généralement plus défavorable
celui ou celle en l'occurrence qui gagne
le moins d'argent et donc défavorable
aux femmes de manière générale l’autrice
insiste également sur le manque
d'éducation financière qui pèse sur les
femmes et les jeunes filles car en
s'appuyant sur les travaux et de
nombreuses études titulent coq démontre
que les jeunes hommes et garçons sont
très vite encouragés à gérer un budget à
investir tandis que les jeunes femmes et
les filles sont souvent considérées
comme dépensières et sont rarement
responsabilisés face aux questions
financières enfin on se rend compte
aussi d'après les dires de l'Autriche
que les parents auront par exemple
tendance à donner moins d'argent de
poche à leur fille qu'elle regarde ça et
à plutôt leur faire des petits cadeaux
alors pour expliquer aussi toutes ces
différences il faut regarder du côté des
stéréotypes de genre des stéréotypes de
gens qui persistent effectivement c'est
stéréotypes qui enferme en fait les
femmes dans des rôles sociaux qui les
empêchent souvent de se concentrer
autant que les hommes sur leur carrière
professionnelle c'est ainsi que les
femmes se voient finalement continuer à
assumer et à prendre en charge encore
une grande partie des tâches domestiques
au détriment bien sûr leur carrière
professionnelle mais aussi qui sont les
premières à recourir des contrats à
temps partiel notamment pour s'occuper
des enfants souvenez-vous d'ailleurs en
2020 en mars 2020 devant durant le
premier confinement les femmes ont été
plus nombreuses que les hommes à
recourir alors un temps partiel ou même
avoir quitter leur emploi pour certaines
pour s'occuper de leurs enfants 21% pour
les femmes et 12% pour les hommes enfin
il faut savoir que les politiques
publiques pardon peuvent-elles aussi
contribuer à couvrir les femmes ou en
tout cas les maintenir dans les
situations de précarité souvenez-vous du
plan de relance qui a été annoncé par
l'exécutif en septembre 2020 35
milliards d'euros sur la table pas un
centime pour les métiers qui
concernaient les femmes ou plus
particulièrement les femmes pardon les
métiers essentiels
de supermarché ou souvent les femmes ont
recours à des à des temps partiels etc
donc 35 milliards qui étaient
essentiellement fléchés sur l'industrie
du de la tech pardon de la technologie
de l'énergie des secteurs qui sont
essentiellement occupés par des jeunes
enfin ce qu'on peut se dire aujourd'hui
c'est qu'ils sont plus que jamais
nécessaire d'avoir quand même une
approche genre et des politiques
publiques notamment en matière
économique et en matière d'emplois
surpris ou pas non non en fait
d'ailleurs dans le livre
femmes que de milliards d'hommes y
compris dans le en tête de classement on
a la chance en France d'en avoir une
Françoise Meyer Bettencourt qui est la
fille de Liliane et je dois avouer que
dans les témoignages
qui n'est pas une gouverne pas ça c'est
une jolie petite qui est une jolie
entreprise française
mais elle en fait un champion mondial et
elle en fait et c'est elle qui se
débrouille pour que cette entreprise la
conduise à être la femme la plus riche
du monde après avoir été d'ailleurs
plusieurs années la femme la plus riche
de France donc elle elle c'est une
championne moyen du boulot il y a quand
même encore du boulot d'ailleurs du plus
bas au plus haut hein de laisser des
revenus mais quand même c'était la
meilleure actionnaire de sa génération
parce que en fait ce qu'on oublie
souvent on se dispute sur les patrons
des sommes que touche les patrons qui
sont salariés mais en fait elle c'est
une actionnaire c'est à dire qu'elle vit
des revenus de son capital et elle a su
à chaque fois bien le placer trouver les
hommes pour le gérer parce qu'elle a
fait travailler des hommes et pas
forcément des femmes ce qu'on pourrait
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui lui reprocher et
c'est comme ça qu'elle a constitué ce
géant qu'elle aurait à la donc oui
cette éducation financière dont parle
titulatif
des filles à gérer un budget c'est vrai
merci à Fabrice d'Almeida merci les
affranchis d'être venu sur le plateau
avec vos chroniques histoire mondiales
des riches pourquoi ils sont le vrai
pouvoir aux éditions plomb très belle
soirée sur LCP soirée documentaire bien
sûr avec Jean-Pierre Gratien demain même
[Musique]